[Music]
Jurassic world's fallen Kingdom and only
we have some of the coolest
behind-the-scenes footage you will ever
see it's just the beginning
Jurassic world the sequel there let's do
it somebody who doesn't really know what
an acrobat is how would you describe
like your job it really depends today it
is important for me to walk down a
stream and turn my head a certain
direction and squint my eyes 3 2 1
action Chris and Bryce are together
again in this latest installment of the
3.7 billion dollar franchise having a
blast on set along with Chris's son Jack
feels so nice to be back here in Hawaii
we're picking up a movie a few years
after the events of Jurassic world I
know how we're here
a rescue off heroine save the dinosaurs
from Island that's about to explode the
Indo Raptor Jurassic world fallen
kingdom boasts more dinosaurs than all
the other draft movies combined and get
this they're not completely
computer-generated there's a team of
puppeteers who handle all the big
movements each of these levers you see
there are so many of them each one
controls a different portion of her from
each of her fingers and so if I lift
this up
watch if I go like this like its hand is
moving or something right now I probably
cost of production $100,000 in like
three days
oh but you're worth it Chris Pratt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]